everybody Sean McGinnis here with the GS
news update the latest on Borderlands
the pre-sequel is that it could be
bigger than the first game but smaller
than the second and the price has not
yet been decided Gearbox Software
president Randy Pitchford said about the
upcoming Borderlands game it's pretty
big I don't think it's going to be as
big as Borderlands 2 it might be as big
or a little bigger than Borderlands one
it might be kind of in between the two
concerning the price point pitchford
said that the final decision is up in
the air and ultimately it'll be decided
by publisher 2k games he said as far as
the price goes I don't think that's set
in stone yet it should be priced
correctly so we'll have to see what
happens in the market and understand the
actual total value proposition that's
being offered but I'm the developer the
guys at 2k will figure that out
Borderlands the pre-sequel launches this
fall on 360 ps3 and pc will have all
your latest Borderlands info here on
gamespot com